kim potter sealed dante wright's fate in
a matter of seconds
now in a minneapolis courtroom it's
potter's future that will be decided
prosecutors are asking for a seven-year
prison sentence for potter convicted in
december of manslaughter her lawyers are
asking for probation in what they say
was a tragic accident
remember yelling taser taser taser
and nothing happened
police camera video shows wright
apparently trying to escape a traffic
stop potter fires what she says she
thought was a taser
the weapon she drew was her gun
wright was killed by potter just as
protesters filled the streets of
minneapolis during the trial of derek
chovin a white police officer later
convicted of killing another black man
george floyd
earlier this month the minneapolis swat
team serving a no-knock warrant shot
amir loft to death as he rose from his
living room sofa holding a legal gun in
his own home
they were looking for someone else the
incident marks the latest killing of a
black man by a white police officer i
don't think these
trials are going to make a difference
that we're seeing violence against young
black men and women
i don't think is is surprising i think
it's alarming and we do need to get to
the root of it to stop this
homicide charges are rare in the u.s for
a police officer acting on duty
convictions are rarer still and when
they do come down sentences tend to be
lighter when the killer wears a badge
after shooting laquan mcdonald 16 times
as he walked away from police knife in
hand chicago police officer jason van
dyke was convicted of murder but
released earlier this month after
serving less than half of his nearly
seven year sentence sentencing does
matter it has to set a precedence jason
van dyke was the first chicago police
officer on duty in 50 years to be tried
and convicted for for murder period but
what that says is is that yes the
activist community and the organizing
community in chicago have been doing
great work but the judicial system
in chicago the judicial system in cook
county is failing us as she hands down
her ruling for kim potter the judge
can't help but be aware that the
sentence in the courtroom will also
resonate outside john hendren al jazeera
minneapolis